the best way to be heard is to First
listen my name is Matt Abrahams and I
teach strategic communication at
Stamford Graduate School of Business
welcome to think fast talk smart the
[Music]
podcast today I am really excited to
speak with Julian treasure Julian is an
expert on listening speaking and sound
he has presented five TED Talks that
have been viewed over 100 million times
he is a speaker coach and author of how
to be heard secrets of powerful speaking
and listening Julian thanks for being
here well thank you for having me yes I
I have to admit that I'm a bit of a
fanboy for your content I've used your
talks in my classes for years and I look
forward to our conversation shall we get
started please all right over the course
of our many episodes the importance and
value of listening in our personal and
professional lives has been mentioned
time and time again can you share why
listening is so important and can you
distinguish among different types of
listening like what you term partial and
conscious listening well listening is
crucial because conscious listening
always creates understanding and I don't
think I'd have to persuade many people
listening to this of the importance of
understanding in in the world today and
indeed the importance of listening never
have we needed it more than we do and
the ABS of listening the absence of
conscious listening tends to put us on a
slippery slope which is enormously
accelerated I think by the current
technology that surrounds us so you see
more and more people descending into
silos of entrenched opinion and not
listening in a way that's actually going
to create new ideas or challenge their
opinions Barack Obama said a good thing
in his acceptance speech she said I will
listen to you especially when we
disagree and I think that's quite an
important attitude to have in the world
but we don't really very much these days
so listening is the basis of all human
understanding it's the basis of
relationship after all what's the most
common complaint in relationships he or
she never listens to me it's the way we
learn Pythagoras it's said in ancient
Greece used to erect a screen in front
of the lecturer so that the students who
he called ausmat were not distracted by
seeing the person speaking from the
important business of learning which of
course is listening so he considered
Vision to be very distracting from the
real business of listening listening is
how we can sell or persuade or enroll
people as well of course any great
salesperson will tell you the most
important part of a sales conversation
is not the speaking it's the listening
because how can you sell to somebody if
you don't understand exactly what their
problem is and how you can solve it so
we've all had the experience of somebody
battering us with sales stuff that
really isn't relevant at all and that's
simply because they're not good
listeners so in all sorts of areas of
human life Leadership as well of course
it's very difficult to lead people and
inspire people and if you're not
listening to them if you don't
understand them and understand what
makes them tick so it's crucial at every
level of human endeavor really and
particularly Human Relationships I think
you have made a very persuasive case for
the importance of listening it's about
understanding connecting influencing and
the ability for us to be successful one
of the skills that I make sure my
students listen to when they watch your
talks is the four-step process you teach
to be a more effective listener you call
it rasa would you be willing to walk us
through those four steps and perhaps
even give examples about how we can
Implement them in our lives yes and
russer again actually that came in the
talk on listening but it straddles both
sides of the communication so it's very
much also about speaking so Russa the
Sanskrit word for juice as I discovered
when I was creating This Acronym it
stands for receive appreciate summarize
ask so four steps and it's a very good
way to be in a conversation if you bear
it in mind and kind of work these four
steps so receive means what we were
talking about before really paying
attention to the person who's speaking
now in the western world I mean this
differs culturally but in the Western
World it tends to be that the person
speaking will glance around and from
time to time glance back at The Listener
to make sure that they're still
listening but they
won't maintain constant eye contact you
see people doing that on TV actually I
mean that's how it works people stand
roughly a foot apart nose to noose
talking to each other and looking at
each other and it's it looks fine on TV
but if you try doing that in real life
it's very intimidating and unnatural
actually so that tends to be when you're
speaking you're looking around thinking
maybe looking out but having ideas
checking in but the listener needs to be
maintaining eye contact we all know the
feeling of speaking to somebody who is
gazing out of the window or thinking
about what they're going to have for
lunch or evidently distracted even worse
falling asleep if you're giving a talk
or something like that looking
interested is really helpful in a
conversation so that would be perhaps
leaning slightly forward as opposed to
lulling back it would be definitely
looking at the person who's speaking
your whole body I mean there's a lot of
body language stuff here not having your
feet pointing at the door not having
your your body angled away from the
person as if you're trying to get ready
to flee so all of these little symbols
and signs can indicate that you're with
them or you're not with them and if you
really switch on this receive it makes
the conversation far more powerful and
it makes the other person feel more
comfortable which is particularly
important if they're not necessarily A
practiced or powerful speaker so that's
the r of receip and I'm just going to
interrupt very quickly just to say you
do a fantastic job we've been doing this
conversation obviously people are
listening only to us but as I'm speaking
I notice you doing all of the things
that you've mentioned and I find myself
now trying to do what you've just
mentioned as you speak so you're not
only explaining it but you're practicing
it and and I invite you to continue now
please with the other three steps well
thank you and it has to be qualified in
different environments or different
contexts I talk about speaking listening
that Circle happening in a context and
there's always a context it might be
terrible Acoustics we don't have that
right now but in radio for example I
mean if we couldn't see each other then
you have to be a little bit more careful
if there's an interview it's very
irritating if the interviewer is
constantly doing what I'm about to
suggest we do now which is appreciation
so the appreciate is the little noises
that we make to oil conversation oh
really wow uh-huh that kind of thing
which you're not doing because it would
be irritating for the people listening
to this to have that constant
Interruption from you and I wouldn't do
it to you either so what we can do also
is visual signals and that's little nods
Bobs of the head raises of the eyebrows
Smiles all those kind of little visual
signals that say I'm listening I'm with
you that's interesting and so forth so
again the nonverbal side of this the
visual side of this is quite important
if you can see somebody and if you can't
you can't so that doesn't matter and in
which case I mean typically in a podcast
if I can't see the person I'm talking to
then it's a question of listening more
intently and more carefully radio and
podcasting doesn't like dead air so you
can't have great big silences but
equally you don't want this kind of
thing going on in that Medium so it is a
question of context and thinking
carefully if you're in a very noisy
place for example then you may need to
really be more vifer in your
appreciation so that's the a rasa the S
is
summarizing and I want to form a society
for preservation of the word so which is
a sorely abused word now so is a way to
summarize and shut doors as you go down
the corridor of the conversation you can
shut doors behind you and lock things
down so what I understood you to say is
this is that right yeah okay let's move
on or in a meeting if you don't have a
so person in the meeting it can be be a
very very long meeting indeed so what
we've all agreed is this can we take it
that that's right yes okay well let's
move on to the next item on the agenda
what is it they say about meetings
places where you take minutes and waste
hours which can absolutely be the case
if you don't have a so person you can go
round and round and round so can we all
just summarize what we believe in this
so we can move on it's a very important
word in a conversation so that's the
word so and I use it to mean therefore
there and then we have the a at the end
which is ask and that's questions
ideally open-ended questions why what
where which who those kind of questions
which don't permit the answer yes or no
and one thing actually I get asked a lot
by people who perhaps feel it's
difficult for them to make themselves
heard is how can I do that how can I
engage when people don't listen to me
well asking questions in a conversation
is a very good way of engaging people
and making a connection and particularly
if I'm talking to somebody who's going
on about something I know nothing at all
about I am thinking hard about how could
I bridge this but it's a really good way
of trying to build a bridge in the
conversation and to offer something you
do know something about or to take it
onto territory you feel a bit more
comfortable with so that's rasa receive
appreciate summarize ask it sounds
complicated now that I've gone into it
in a bit of detail but it's really
simple and it's a great thing just to
practice with friends family colleagues
people at work whoever it might be that
you will find it makes a big difference
in
communication so thank you very much I I
purposely wanted to throw the sew in
there I have found this over the years
to be very helpful to me it's been very
helpful to my students this notion of
receive appreciate summarize and ask I
love the idea of having a so person not
just in meetings but in life and I think
many of us can examine the situations we
are in and determine if we need to be
that person to help summarize and I just
want to note for our listeners and to
compliment you on the fact that you do a
very nice job at the end of each of your
answers doing your own summary and
that's something that I think many of us
fail to do we just rattle off all of our
points hoping that our listeners can
aggregate them in some way and make
sense of them but often especially when
speaking for a little bit summarizing
for our audience for our listener can be
helpful one of the most important
lessons that has emerged from the many
experts I've interviewed on this podcast
is that we must be audience Centric in
our communication you have your own spin
on this that I really really like you
ask what is the listening I am speaking
into can you shed light on what you mean
by this and how can we adapt our
communication depending on the type of
listening that we expect well this comes
from my observation that every human
being's listening is unique it's as
unique as your fingerprints are and the
reason for that is that we listen
through a set of filters and those
filters develop as we grow and mature in
life and we have experiences so they
start with things like the language we
learn to speak the culture we're born
into which might be family it might be
tribe or group it might be local it
might be City it might be region might
be National whatever it is might be all
of those things there's a culture we're
born into and these things shape our
listening and then you have the values
attitudes and beliefs that you gather
along the way from parents teachers
friends Role Models you you pick some up
you discard others and the ones you've
picked up will be the different from the
ones I've picked up up and then in any
situation we might have expectations we
might have intentions we might have
emotions going on we might have
assumptions about particularly what's
going on in other people's heads which
is a big area and those things change
our listening so I don't think he likes
me then you're listening in a different
way so the emotional St I mean do you
listen in a different way if you've just
had fabulous news from if you've just
had some terrible news of course you do
so so people's listening changes over
time and listening changes from person
to person so it's very important to ask
that question what's the listening I'm
speaking into because you're always
speaking into somebody's listening and
that listening is unique to them now
whether it's one person or a thousand if
you put a thousand people in a room you
get a kind of guest thought listening
and it is perfectly possible if you
simply ask this question over and over
again to yourself becomes a
practice then you become more and more
sensitive to it and it's possible to
sense the
listening I can't give you any more
formal scientific explanation than that
but I can tell you from my experience
that when I walk on stage in a hall be
it Ted or 10,000 people or 50 people or
I'm talking to an individual I'm
thinking what's the listening I'm
speaking into and that makes me
sensitive to it
and it will change that's why anybody
who's a public speaker it's a very good
idea to be there early and to make sure
that you've understood what the audience
has just experienced before you they
might have had a brilliant speaker who
made them laugh and cry and so forth oh
wow I've got I've really got to raise my
game here or they might have had
somebody who's really pissed them off
and they might be seething and very
upset so you need to know those things
otherwise you're walking on and you
really don't know what you're walking
into so sensing it asking that question
what's the listening I'm speaking into
is how you hit the bullseye instead of
missing the target all together with
your speaking and I'm talking here about
what you choose to say and how you
choose to say it as well pace energy the
vocabulary you use and the topics you're
going to cover and how you roll them out
all of those things are very different
if you're talking to an audience of
septuagenarians as opposed to an
audience of kids or an AUD a perhaps who
don't speak your language very well and
they're having to translate
simultaneously I've seen people in that
situation Go on stage and rattle off
very fast English and the people in the
audience are just looking what is he
talk I can't keep up right so it's very
important to ask that question what's
the listening I'm speaking into I love
the perspective change that that
question requires it forces us to really
think about what we're bringing to the
audience and how we can help them digest
what it is we're saying too often we
come in with the approach that it's all
about what I want to say it's really
what your audience needs to hear and by
asking yourself about the listening you
are speaking into it really has us focus
on that and I appreciate that very much
and thank you for sharing well of course
it's never about you is it and that's
one of the most important things to
understand as a speaker it's not about
me it's about the gift I'm giving to
those people and that's where the four
foundations that I talk about come in
and so forth of powerful speaking so
it's giving them a gift and the more
you're involved in that and what's
happening it's getting the ball over the
net does it get received because if not
you're wasting your time and theirs
right and I love that analogy of a gift
because many people have a great fear of
speaking in front of others and a lot of
that has to do with our self focus and
when we REM ourselves that we have value
to bring a gift to give it can change
our own internal assessment of our
confidence and anxiety and I appreciate
that in addition to listening you focus
a lot on speaking and in particular you
give guidance on how to nurture and hone
our voice can you give us a few examples
of things that we can do with our voice
and activities that we can practice so
that we can tune our voice to maximally
be listened to well a couple of things I
would suggest first of all breathing now
in most people's lives unless you are a
very strong on exercise for example
breathing tends to be something we do
very little of actually we breathe in a
very shallow fashion most of the time
and it's not a conscious Pursuit now
that's not the case for everybody there
are people who've got breathing
practices there's yoga which focuses
entirely on breathing even and all yoga
uses breathing but if the people
listening to this haven't a breathing
practice that would be a strong
recommendation of mine if you want to
speak powerfully develop a breathing
practice and that can be as simple as
conscious breathing which is breathing
in through the nose out through the
mouth so in through the nose is silent
out through the mouth as if you're
whistling and count it so that you start
to extend the length of time that you
can breathe in for and the length of
time you breathe out for and just take
that on as a practice you don't have to
do it all the time but just a few times
a day if you spend five minutes 10
minutes doing this you start to become
more acquainted with your lungs you
become conscious of what's going on
there because your voice is just
breath also breath is very important if
you ever feel nervous because you when
you come on the stage and your voice is
a little bit like that then a big deep
breath is the thing that will settle
your voice right down so it's it's a
powerful tool as well in stress
situations but it's also very important
to be able to breathe effectively and
that's without getting into the
technicalities of diaphragm control and
all that stuff that singers know a great
deal about so that's the first thing I'd
say in terms of improving anybody's
voice is is to get to know your
breathing and then I think the other
thing would be to take on some of the
tools in the vocal toolbox that I talk
about which may be prid or proad
intonation being a big part of that or
it might be volume or it might be pacing
and to start to play with them and
extend your
range now that requires perhaps a quiet
place to practice where you're not going
to bother other people I used to do
seminar work with groups of people I've
had people in those seminars going I am
shouting that's as loud as I can go no
really that's not true that's your
perception but we can all extend our
range in terms of how loud we can go and
how quiet we can go just get a book a
novel whatever it might be and start to
read to yourself and extend your range
really exaggerate the intonation so
you're really going to mad about this
kind of thing which you wouldn't
necessarily do on stage but it's like
training muscles and if you do a lot of
pull-ups or push-ups or barbell things
or whatever it might be you get your
muscles get stronger and you're more
capable to lift something when you need
to and that's exactly what it's like
again with Pace being able to slow write
down when you need to perhaps that's the
listening that I'm speaking into but
also being able to go faster and faster
when you need to and that is crucial for
avoiding monotony as is changing the
tone monotone of course is where the
word monotony comes from boredom comes
from somebody who's got very little
inflection or intonation and just speaks
on One Tone the whole time well if
that's you work at it practicing
extending your range with all these
things and being able to stop those
three words extend your range is my
strongest hint to anybody who wants to
become a more powerful
speaker many many very practical bits of
advice there and thank you when I look
at this kind of work I remind people
that our brains are wired for variety
for change when things become stagnant
we stop paying attention to them in the
same way and your points all lead us to
have variation in variety one of the
things I encourage the students I teach
to do is to take children's poetry or
children's books which are often meant
to be read in a very exaggerated way to
do exactly what you're talking about to
extend that range and to build what I
call vocal stamina the ability to
support your voice for long periods of
time and those exercises you reviewed
for us are very helpful ways so thank
you many of us Focus so much on our
content we don't think about how to use
our voice well to deliver that content
and the tips you gave can help us to do
that so Julian before we end I'd like to
ask you the same three questions I ask
everyone who joins me are you up for
that I am if you were to capture the
best communication advice you have ever
received in a five to seven-word present
slide title what would it be ask what's
the listing yes yes simply that is so
crucial and it's the thing that so many
people Overlook to do because it all
becomes about them it becomes about the
sender and the receiver is the person
that matters always whether it's one
person or 10,000 it doesn't matter so
ask what's the listing is absolutely the
most important thing I would put that in
huge letters across the slide absolutely
and certainly not a surprising answer
yet a very important one question number
two and I'll be very curious to get your
answer to this who is a communicator
that you admire and
why I had the great pleasure of meeting
Ken Robinson at a lunch break at Ted in
Vancouver some years ago and his Ted
Talk is number one for a reason when you
see him live He's a master
me I've seen a lot of great talkers I
was in the room for Brian Stevenson's
amazing talk bernee Brown Susan Kane
I've seen lot of people who've been very
very good and I'm in awe of the people
who don't need notes and can just rattle
things off from memory but I think Ken
because he combines
humor often very self-effacing humor and
storytelling in such a m Majestic Way I
mean he does it naturally Ken would be
sadly missed now but a wonderful rack on
a brilliant speaker and a wonderful
Communicator excellent and that is an
amazing talk question number three final
question what are the first three
ingredients that go into a successful
communication recipe content has to be
number one I asked this question to
Chris Anderson actually when I
interviewed him for my book how to be
heard and I said to him which one's more
important content or delivery and he
said well it has to be content because
if somebody is delivering Earth
shattering content in a boring way I'll
stay with them but if somebody's
delivering absolute nonsense brilliantly
it's just
irritating and I think there's a lot of
Truth in that so content has to come
first and there's a great deal in
thinking about what it is that you're
going to put across the biggest question
I think with content has got to be so
what that's what newspaper editors beat
into their their drum into their traine
journalists and you have to have the
first paragraph should say everything
and it has to say why would you want to
read the rest of this so what why is the
reader going to be interested why is the
listener going to be interested what's
in it for them so content first then
delivery yes I mean thinking about the
vocal toolbox all the the amazing tools
that we've got I mean the human voices
and extraordinary thing and most people
take it as a given this is the voice
I've been given no obviously there are
physiological aspects to this some
people have got deeper voices others
don't we are different shapes we have
different vocal cords different
resonating Chambers but you can do so
much with whatever you've been given to
extend it and when I hear any great
great amazing singer I just think my
goodness what the human voice can do and
I've done quite a bit of training but
I'm not scratching the surface off it so
content first and then delivery and then
the third thing I would say is taken
from my four foundations of powerful
speaking hail which is honesty
authenticity integrity and it be the
fourth one of those which is love that
is to say wishing people well and that
comes back to giving the gift so if
you're actually wishing somebody well
and giving them a gift of
something they're much more likely to
receive it and appreciate it than if
you're all about how important you are
and standing on your Hill above them and
and bestowing Pearls of Wisdom down to
the swine below and that's not going to
go down so well so yes I think content
delivery and love would be my three
ingredients super powerful content
delivery and
love so Julian thank you so much for
your time today it was fantastic to
speak with you you certainly didn't
disappoint you provided wonderful
information insight and specific
practical and tactical tools that we can
use thank you for your time I encourage
everybody to listen to your TED talks
and to get your book how to be heard
secrets of powerful speaking and
listening thank you very much well
thanks for having me it's been an
absolute
pleasure thanks for listening to another
episode EP of think fast talk smart the
podcast to gain more insights and
information please follow us on LinkedIn
and Instagram you can also help us
spread the word by rating and reviewing
our show on Apple or Spotify you can
find transcripts for all of our episodes
via the link in the show notes and on
the Stanford GSB website this episode
was produced by Jenny Luna Ryan Campos
Podium podcast and me Matt
Abrahams if you liked our topic today we
have more interviews that dive deeply
into listening our episode listen listen
listen how to build deep connections
from earlier this spring shares tips on
being a skilled
conversationalist and in April of last
year I sat down with one of my co- teers
for an episode we called are you
listening how to stay open and curious
to other people's ideas in it Kristen
Hansen and I talk about the importance
of really hearing where others are
coming from another you might enjoy is
forgiveness how the right communication
repairs relationships this episode
features Fred lusin and we look at
research showing how forgiveness affects
our psychological relational and
physical health our music was provided
by Floyd Wonder for more episodes find
us on YouTube or wherever you get your
podcasts